we all know that a scalar quantity is a  quantity that has only magnitude and no  direction it's simply a numerical value  while a vector quantity has magnitude as  well as direction example say you live  at point a and your friend lives at  point b which is two kilometers away  from point a now if i ask you how far  away does your friend live from you your  answer would simply be two kilometers  this is the distance and it's a scalar  quantity and what if you were asked  where does your friend live relative to  your place well you can't just say two  kilometers away because it could mean  anywhere on the circumference here you'd  probably say two kilometers north and  this is called displacement and it's a  vector quantity  magnitude as well as direction go ahead  share this video with your friends  [Music]